Tom Norton is the CEO of Second City
work second city is the famed Chicago
comedy club but it also has a consulting
business and Tom just co-authored the
book yes and which argues that improv
skills improved creativity and
collaboration on stage and also in the
workplace Tom great to see you thanks
for having me ok so lighting us up a
little bit here how does improv actually
help in the workplace yeah business is
an act of improvisation for all the
planning and controls and governance
curveballs happen I mean you see that in
your business all the time right and we
found that the same skills that our
improvisers have and need to be
successful on stage translate really
nicely in the business how to listen how
to read a room how to react to tough
problems in the moment think on your
feet all those things are things that
our people are really good at and those
things all transfer really importantly
and nicely into the business world and
so that's what the books about so tell
me a little bit about how you're working
with other CEOs are working with big
corporations some of the skills you're
learning that you already have and
mastered at second city how do you
translate that to the c-suite yeah
absolutely we do a lot of work with
individuals but also in TAC teams at the
sea level things are on presentation
executive presence storytelling helping
them make a more genuine and authentic
connection with their audience which is
what our heart people are really so good
at right that's that's a common thing
that we do we also do a lot of work
where we create fun video content where
you use comedy to help T up tough thorny
issues things around you know ethics and
compliance things around HR and training
practices things that are typically not
where you find compelling interesting
content we put a fun happy spin you give
me some specific examples of clients
you've worked with yeah I'd say over
half the fortune 1000 and her partner
for our ethics and compliance business
is New York Stock Exchange government
services Major League Baseball you work
with them as well absolutely for 14
years running we've worked with them
with the rookie development program
really using comedy improv to help them
better handle some of the stresses that
are gonna experience down the road Tom
you mentioned authentic story-telling
writing man I find that that's something
that's very difficult only a few
companies have really mastered that and
individuals themselves so so what is it
that you work how do you work on it
particularly with CEO
to talk about authentic storytelling
without sort of crossing that line where
you might reveal too much you might be
almost too authentic to the world yeah
for us it's really understanding that
what makes you credible and
authoritative may be different than what
makes me credible and authoritative a
lot of training methods when they're
working with execs are prescriptive use
this do this ABC and you'll be great and
a lot of times executives it's like
clothes that don't fit you well you've
got to find what your voices and be
confident in your own approach and we're
able to help people identify unearthed
and hone those things so they can be
better in the moment all right Tom great
to see you thank you so much for
stopping by and giving us some of those
tips on improv that was Tom you're the
CEO of second city works and also author
of the new book yes